STARS, CELEBRITIES, AND ATHLETES
WHO INSIST ON GETTING POLITICAL.
THE HUMANLESS OUT OF TOUCH
AMERICAN LEFT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANKHLE.
-- ANGLE.
OVER THE WEEKEND CNN RELEASED
COMMENTS PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE AT
AND HE SAID.
>> I THINK IT'S GREAT.
HE IS A GREAT GENTLEMAN.
HE IS NOW A PRESIDENT FOR LIFE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Laura: I CAN'T DO TRUMP AS
GOOD AS TRUMP CAN DO TRUMP.
IT'S OBVIOUS THIS WAS SOMETHING
CALLED A JOKE!
IT'S OBVIOUS TO EVERYONE EXCEPT
AMERICA'S RESISTANCE MEDIA WHICH
HAS LOST TOUCH WITH REALITY.
>> IT'S A CONSOLIDATION OF
POWER.
IT'S IMPRACTICAL AND
COUNTER-PRODUCTIVE.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS CRAZY.
HE'S BEEN COMPARED TO MAO.
>> IS IT GOOD FOR ME AND MY
IMAGE
IMAG
IMAGE.
>> FEELS GOOD TO SAY IT RIGHT
NOW.
>> MORE VISCERAL.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THE PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM PROBABLY WERE
LAUGHING NERVOUSLY AT?
I DON'T KNOW.
I WASN'T THERE.
>> Laura: TOTALLY.
NO MORNING JOKESTERS THERE.
CNN'S CHRIS SAW SOMETHING EVEN
MORE SINISTER.
UNDER THE HEADLINE, THIS MAY BE
THE SCAREST THING DONALD TRUMP
HAS SAID AS PRESIDENT.
HE WROTE:
IT'S NO MORE CHILLING THAN WHAT
HE SAID AT THE GRID IRON DINNER.
IT WAS A FUN, COMEDIC EVENT FOR
THE D.C. AND BUSINESS POWER
PLAYERS.
AGAIN, THIS IS HUMOR.
THE PRESIDENT JOKEINGLY
REFERENCED POSSIBLE TALKS WITH
THE NORTH KOREA DICTATOR KIM
JONG-UN SAYING:
TRUMP WAS MAKING FUN OF HIMSELF.
KNOW WHY THE LEFT IS SO AGITATED
BY THESE JOKES?
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS VEXING
THEM AT THEIR OWN GAME.
IN THE PROCESS, HE IS ENDEARING
HIMSELF TO THE PUBLIC.
I HAVE A QUESTION: WHY SHOULD
THE LEFT BE THE ONLY GROUP
ALLOWED TO ENGAGE IN A LITTLE
SARCASM, A LITTLE COMEDY AND
SELF-DEPRICATING HUMOR?
THE LEFT DOESN'T MIND DISHING IT
OUT, BUT THE MOMENT THE
PRESIDENT OR ANY CONSERVATIVE
RIBS THEM OR THEMSELVES, THERE
IS IMMEDIATE BLOWBACK.
MOVIE STARS, TELEVISION ACTORS.
THEY SHOOT THEIR MOUTHS OFF ON
POLITICS ALL THE TIME.
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES AND
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO REACT AS IF
PLATO HAD COME BACK TO OPINE ON
CONTEMPORARY ISSUES.
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMENTARY.
IT'S SO WELL INFORMED.
LOOK, EVERYBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK HIS OR HER MIND.
THEY ARE WELCOME TO COME ON THIS
SHOW ANY TIME.
BUT JUST BECAUSE YOU ARE A
CELEBRITY OR GETTING PAID
MILLION DOLLARS TO PLAY A GAME
DOESN'T MEAN YOU GET A FREE PASS
TO OFFER ILLOGICAL ARGUMENTS,
AVOIDING SUBSTANCE AND ENGAGING
IN DRIVE BY MEDIA ATTACKS.
IF YOU DO THAT, YOU SHOULD NOT
BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
IN CASE YOU HAVE NOT HEARD, I
WROTE A BEST SELLING BOOK 15
YEARS AGO CALLED "SHUT UP AND
SING."
I WENT AFTER LEFTISTS LIKE THE
DIXIE CHICKS AND A BUNCH OF ARE
THE CELEBRITIES.
I CALL OUT THESE ELITE WHO FEEL
LIKE THEY ARE CELEBRITY GIVES
THEM POLITICAL AUTHORITY TO
SPEAK ON THE COMPLEX ISSUES OF
THE DAY.
LAST WEEK, WE CAUGHT BARBARA
STREISAND IN A LITTLE BITTY LIE.
SHE CLAIMED THAT THE
PRESIDENTIAL
PRESIDENTIA
PRESIDENT A
IAL ELECTION WAS RIGGED AND SHE
SPOKE TO SENATORS FROM WISCONSIN
AND MICHIGAN.
NO ONE CALLED UP THE 4 SENATORS
FROM THOSE 2 STATES, BUT OUR
PRODUCERS DID.
WE CALLED THE WISCONSIN SENATORS
WHO TOLD US THEY DID NOT SPEAK
TO STREISAND AND SAID NOTHING
ABOUT ELECTION FRAUD.
OOPS.
NOW EVEN FORMER NBA STAR KOBE
BRYANT WON AN ACADEMY AWARD AT
THE ME TOO OSCARS FOR A SMALL
ANIMATED FILM ABOUT BASKETBALL.
THAT'S KIND OF FUN.
THERE IS NOW AN ON LINE PETITION
WITH 16,000 SIGNATURES AND
COUNTING TO RESCIND HIS OSCAR
OWING TO A RAPE ACCUSATION IN
2003.
THEY DID NOT BRING CHARGERS.
THEY SETTLED IT.
KOBE WAS JUST ONE OF THE MANY
WALKARD
WALKAR
WALK ARD
WALK AR
WALKARR
WALKARD
WALKARD  -
WALKARD  --
WALKARD  -- A
WALKARD  -- AWK
WALKARD  -- AWKWA
WALKARD  -- AWKWARD
WALKARD  -- AWKWARD O
WALKARD  -- AWKWARD OSC
WALKARD  -- AWKWARD OSCAR
MOMENTS THAT WERE FAR FROM
FUNNY.
HOST JIMMY KIMMEL IN THE OPENING
MONOLOGUE REFERENCED A BEST
PICTURE NOMINEE.
IT'S ABOUT A 24-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO
HAS INTIMATE RELATIONS WITH A
17-YEAR-OLD BOY.
>> THEY DON'T MAKE FILMS LIKE
THIS FOR MONEY.
WE MAKE THEM TO UPSET MIKE
PENCE.
>> Laura: YOU MIGHT NOT THRILL
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE EQUAL WHO
SAW A FEW ART HOUSE FILMS
CELEBRATED LAST NIGHT.
THE OSCARS FELL TO A 9 YEAR
VIEWERSHIP SLOW
VIEWERSHIP SLO
VIEWERSHIP LOO
VIEWERSHIP LOW
VIEWERSHIP LOW L
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAS
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST Y
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST YEA
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST YEAR
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST YEAR I
VIEWERSHIP LOW LAST YEAR IN
2017.
THIS YEAR YOU OUTDID YOURSELF.
HE PRESIDED OVER THE LOWEST
RATED OSCARS EVER!
NOTHING SAYS HAPPY 90th OSCAR
LIKE A 20% DROP IN THE LOUSY
RATINGS FROM LAST YEAR.
THREE CHEERS.
LET'S FACE IT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE FANATICS SO
THEY DON'T CARE.
>> DREAMS ARE THE FOUNDATION OF
AMERICA.
>> AND TO ALL OF THE DREAMERS
OUT THERE, WE STAND WITH YOU.
>> MARGINALIZED PEOPLE DESERVE
TO FEEL THEY BELONG.
>> Laura: WHO ARE MORE
MARGINALIZED IN HOLLYWOOD THAN
CONSECUTIVE?
OH, CHRISTIAN CONSERVATIVES.
COMPLETE PHONIES.
HOLLYWOOD AND SPORTS FIGURES,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE CONJOB?
THAT'S WHY THEY GET PAID A LOT
OF MONEY.
THEY ENTERTAIN US.
BUT INSTEAD AS WE SAW LAST
NIGHT, THEY GUEST US A BIZARRE
POLITICAL STORY LINES OR
CHARACTERS THAT MOST AMERICANS
CAN'T RELATE TO.
THEN HOLLYWOOD ENDS UP ATTACKING
A LOT OF VALUES AND IDEASES THAT
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS HOLD DEAR.
THEN WHEN THEY ARE CRITICIZED,
THEY CRY LIKE INFANTS BEING
WEANED, WHICH MAKES SENSE, SINCE
MANY OF THEM ARE USED TO FEEDING
OFF THEIR STAFF AND MEDIA
ENABLERS.
THEY ARE NOT USED TO CRITICISM.
ALL OF THIS IS A BIG TURN OFF TO
THE AUDIENCE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS TO
CHOOSE FROM, DON'T THEY?
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY THESE
CELEBRITIES ARE SO NASTY TO THE
PRESIDENT AND SO UPSET WHEN HE
OR ANY CONSERVATIVE DARIUS TO
CRACK A JOKE, WELL, I HAVE AN
ANSWER.
FOR ALL OF THEIR VILE DIRECTED
AT CONSERVATIVES AND THE
PRESIDENT, YOU KNOW WHAT HE
KEEPS DOING?
PUTTING IT IN A LANGUAGE THAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS: HE PUTS
POINTS ON THE BOARD FOR THE
AMERICAN WORKER.
OUR AUDIENCE IS GROWING WHILE
THE OSCAR'S AUDIENCE IS TANKING.